[Music]
we became friends with the family of
wild dolphins
and this is their story hey i'm mark i'm
not and this is this
we're a group of friends who surf subway
and really we try to get out there and
appreciate these beautiful by nature
islands as much as we possibly can
the turks and caicos pretty much has
consistent flat water the entire year
round
so we don't tend to get any surfable
waves here so luckily we've got these
amazing boats that kick up huge waves
for our guests for ourselves and
that's kind of become our favorite sport
i think about three
four years ago we were out filming we'd
actually brought my dog along as well we
were kicking up the waves this was out
and about in the water
this wild dolphin just came right up to
us started playing around the boat
turns out this dolphin's name is jojo
he's been swimming around the islands of
providenciales
for the last 40 or so years everybody
has an incredible story interacting with
him
locals tourists a lot he's definitely a
bit of an adrenaline junkie
he's one of his favorite activities to
do is to surf just as we love surfing he
loves catching that wave sadly he
doesn't get the opportunity
to ocean surf so we kind of had a bit of
a mutual agreement where we kick up a
wave and he'll come and join us and
both share the wave together he'll come
up in front of the boat and he'll
actually lift his tail out the water and
give a nice big old slap
just before the boat reaches him almost
to say like you know yeah let's go
he gets pumped up as soon as anyone on
the boat starts cheering screaming
shouting when they get excited when he's
around he definitely
starts surfacing more jumps a little bit
higher he really kind of thrives off
that excitement that he
hears from other people
[Applause]
so jojo has actually been known
occasionally to protect humans from
sharks so he's kind of if there's ever
if
sharks aren't dangerous but occasionally
i guess maybe if like there's an object
in the water maybe
he might think that a human is a little
uncertain around the shark and he's
definitely been known to put himself in
between the human and the shark and try
and scare the shark off
so this is a true water dog he really
kind of suited the lifestyle here and
just loves getting in the water whenever
he gets the chance
jojo's specifically been known to make
lifelong friends with a lot of different
dogs through the years
and we have a feeling that when the
dog's out in the water the dolphin tends
to kind of seek him out
the first few times that they they met
they kind of really kicked it off
and whenever this is out on the boat now
and and the dolphins are around he's
straight in the dolphins get super
excited else just start swimming around
and he'll just follow them and tail them
around
they'll turn he'll turn and they just
like to follow each other in a little
dolphin train almost
it's amazing to watch joey joe's got a
little baby dreamer who
is super friendly just like jojo and
he's slowly starting to teach her to
surf as well he's teaching her
that humans can be friends she's really
picked up off him and she really gets
his stove as well
you can pick up bits of coral and she'll
come and grab it swim around with it
it'll go over part of her fin like
almost like she's carrying it
and it just becomes this incredible game
that you're playing with
you know a little dolphin it's amazing
beau is dreamer's mum
jojo's i guess dolphin wife she is
always alongside dreamer you'll never
see duma by herself
you'll always see beau looking after
dreamer jojo occasionally cruises around
by himself but beau is always looking
after dreamer
we we've built up a relationship now
with dreama where beau trusts us
and what she'll do is she'll leave baby
jimmy with us and she'll go off fishing
and go and do her little thing and then
she'll come back pick dreamer up and
she'll take her away
beau is more reserved jojo is definitely
a thrill seeker
maybe they have different parenting
ideas we don't know
so they tried to implement a
dolphinarium down here
several years ago um it was actually on
grand turk where all the cruise ship
industry comes in so all the big cruise
ships go to that island
they were proposing to put a
dolphinarium up in one of the creeks on
the island it got massive backlash
nobody wanted it to happen part of the
whole like campaign that came from that
was like we had these stickers which
said jojo says no
to captivity and you'd be hard-pressed
to go around this island and not see
that on the back of someone's car here
we love dolphins being in the wild they
swim up to 60 miles a day
on average you know what is the what's
the dolphin gonna do in a little pool
that's not right and thankfully people
down here had the right visions and um
they stopped it jojo's definitely an
ambassador to really
stop this whole captivity thing every
interaction that we have with him is
totally on his terms
and that's how every interaction with a
dolphin should be they they've actually
named him a national treasure
and it's now illegal to to harm him in
any sort of way
he proves that dolphins want to play
with humans that they can be friendly
that they can give these amazing
memories to everybody
without having to be forced to do so and
it's amazing to watch
[Applause]
[Music]
you